i think conservatives and i include
myself in this
make a mistake when we dismiss
these bizarre actings out as
snowflake-ism
um or something that you know it's the
product of an overly privileged
privileged childhood that's not what i
see in this i see
real suffering
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people i'm delighted to
say we have yet another brilliant guest
for you she is an american author
mary eberstad welcome to trigonometry
thank you constantine and francis thanks
for having me
it's a great pleasure to have you we
wanted really to focus on your
latest book which is primal screams how
the sexual revolution created identity
politics
and that is just a fascinating look into
some of
the many things that we talk about on
the show before we do that just tell
everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey that leads you
through life to be sitting here talking
to us
well thank you i'm an american writer
i've been writing since i could hold a
pencil
i've written in various genres over the
years i wrote a novel at one point in
response to the new
atheism which was produced on stage some
years later
very exciting stuff uh and i've written
in pretty much every genre i'd say apart
from poetry and
reportage i'm not a reporter
and over the years increasingly my focus
became
the sexual revolution and its fallout
because evidence seemed to be
accumulating
that this revolution which is part of
the wallpaper of all of our lives now
has changed uh a lot about humanity and
i think has changed a lot for the worse
and we can
talk about that so you're saying that a
lot has changed but look
let's see some of the narratives uh i
i've certainly been fed
you know it was a time where women had
control over their bodies
all of a sudden it gave them greater
agency over their lives
that you know they could pursue careers
because of the pill etc etc
surely isn't that a universal positive
mary
i'm just thinking before you answer the
question should we maybe define the
sexual revolution for people
who weren't around at the time and maybe
they aren't familiar with it
constantine's never had a sexual
revolution i have not me i've
exactly i've never been overthrown well
i think the most
uncontroversial definition would be the
uh widespread adoption and
destigmatization of contraception that
begins with the introduction of the
birth control pill so
we're going back to the early 1960s here
which is when that all started and in
answer to your question francis
when it all started i think there was a
lot of optimism
i mean i i don't remember it either but
you could see why people would make the
case that this would be a good thing for
humanity that it would
free women as you say um that it would
allow them
to have robust careers etc
but what wasn't clearly seen at the time
was the negative
fallout in the forms of rising
fatherlessness out of wedlock births
truly shocking numbers of abortions
all of these things went up in tandem
with the use of contraception and you
don't have to be a card-carrying
theologian or a religious fanatic
to question some of this stuff in some
of my writing
i cite perfectly secular economists
including nobel prize-winning economists
who look at these numbers and try to
figure out why did it happen that
instead of
strengthening marriages uh strengthening
relationships and improving romance
the widespread adoption of the birth
control pills seemed to have the
opposite effect
and it's a paradox but
it disentangles if we realize that we
should look at this the way economists
do
what contraception did was flood the
marketplace with available sexual
partners
and that diminished the incentives for
everyone but especially for men to
settle down with any one of them
and so here we see the negative fallout
of contraception at its most
crystalline i think because what we see
is that something that was meant to
enhance
relations especially relations between
the sexes
instead ended up being an obstacle to
human happiness in many cases and that's
why we see
when sociologists study happiness
especially among women
over the last couple of decades and
in numerous countries not only in the
united states
what they see is a diminution of
happiness over time
which makes no sense if we're supposed
to be all liberated now
but it does make sense if you realize
that what
women always say they want um in
survey data are families
and husbands most of the time
and so the fact that these things are
now harder to obtain
means that we've introduced a serious
new form of acrimony and unhappiness
into society and there's a lot more that
we could say about that but
the sexual revolution has a lot of other
effects that i think
are now showing up not just between
individuals not just as private
contractual matters but
across society and that's what the last
book
of primal screams is about and so
you were saying about the effects it has
on society
i read the book mary in fact i read it
yesterday i found it
very very powerful and dare i say
harrowing because of the effects
that you explained quite brilliantly
about
the breakdown of the family and how that
has affected society now
in particular as well by the way that
we've embraced identity politics could
you go into that a little bit
for us and tease it apart yes sure and
francis i'm glad to hear that i wrote
something short enough to be read in a
day
my publisher will be happy about that um
so the sexual revolution
and identity politics i would like to
start with what happened in the united
states last summer
because the book came out a year before
the riots and protests in the u.s
and i could not help but feel as if they
vindicated the thesis
of the book because the book argues
that in the absence of
religion in the absence of family in the
absence
of what throughout human history have
been
very primal attachments for all human
beings
in the absence of those things as those
things weaken across the western world
we see an increasingly impassioned
flight
to identity politics to collective
identities
and the reason for that flight is that
you know
fundamental to all of us is the question
who am
i and if you were to ask me who
am i i would probably say something like
uh i'm a mother i'm a catholic
i'm an aunt i'm a wife etc in other
words
my intuitive response would be to define
myself
by my primal attachments what we have to
understand is that in this day and age
a lot of people do not have strong
attachments of that nature
we live in societies that are
secularizing rapidly
so that takes one answer off the table
who am i
i'm a child of god a lot of people
wouldn't say that wouldn't think to say
that don't believe that
but then we get into the more
complicated tangle
of defining oneself by relations to
one's family
and let me say at the outset there's not
a family in the world that is not
affected by the trends that we are
describing we are all in this together
so when i talk about something like
uh say divorce and remarriage
and what that does to the sibling uh
relationships
of people with half brothers step
brothers
etc i i'm coming from a place where
i know as much about this as you do
which is that it's it's ubiquitous
but what these more attenuated
relationships have done
over time is weaken the emotional
uh attachments of people they've
weakened the gravitational
pull that people feel toward their
families and we're not talking about
ozzie and harriet
you know perfect nuclear family we're
talking about
the extended family which for most of us
has shrunk by quite a lot
so i get into this in primal screams for
a couple of reasons
one is that i really do believe that in
the rise
in mental health problems in the
increasing acting out that we see
on campuses uh people duct taping their
mouth
shut people having nervous breakdowns
about pronouns
you know i think what we're seeing is a
deep unraveling
that's coming about because so many
people
especially young people can't answer
that question
who am i um by resort to their
native families if you will and
this leaves a big lacuna that has to be
filled by something
and i think increasingly it's being
filled by identity politics
getting back to what happened in the
streets of the united states
there were in 2020 over ten thousand
incidents of what's politely called
unrest in city after city
and over 500 of these devolved into what
is
impolitely called riots this is
unprecedented in american history
nothing like this has happened
so where is this coming from well of
course the conventional answer
is police brutality and racism and it's
true
that police brutality uh
energized a lot of people especially
young people
uh who were already living under the
restrictions of the pandemic etc
this is what started it but this is not
what kept the momentum
going night after night in cities like
portland
where you would see the same young
people out there
throwing things attacking the police
this does not explain the level of
sheer emotiveness that we saw in these
riots these did not look like
civil rights protests they didn't even
look like anti-vietnam protests from
what i've seen of that footage this was
very
raw primordial stuff
that was in the streets of america
and we can see that very clearly
in the sort of street theater that this
devolved into
where people protesters and rioters were
going around into residential
neighborhoods
shining lights into people's homes as
they were sleeping
or disrupting people who were out trying
to dine
outdoors in the rage that we see in
those acts
i believe we can
see through it to a place where people
are
so unhinged and so devoid of
attachment of primal attachments of
their own
that they are now taking it out on
people who they perceive to have those
things
that is the deeper meaning of all that
anger spilling into residential
neighborhoods and
attacking innocent bystanders who had
nothing to do with police brutality or
racism
but were representative of a
kind of world a kind of order
that many young people are now having
serious trouble finding
and that to me is the deeper meaning of
what we saw in the streets we saw
identity politics as an unstable
substitute for more stable connections
to family and community
and mary you see what i like about your
analysis as well i heard your brilliant
conversation with christina hoff summers
who i have a lot of respect for as well
uh and in the you you talk about how
identity politics
you know it's very fashionable for
people on the right to attack people on
the left were there but actually
you talk also about the rise of the
insult
uh community you talk about the rise of
white nationalism such as it is i'm not
saying it's widespread but
it certainly exists right so the idea of
identifying with a group
uh seems to appeal across the political
spectrum to people
and it certainly makes sense that you
know i i can feel it
you know you talk about being religious
francis and i are both non-believers but
the the awareness of the fact that
people crave community and also
the the emergence of the sort of woke
thing that feels very
religious in nature it's got its
inquisitions it's got its cancel culture
it's got all of that
we i mean it does seem like what you're
saying
is true so i guess the question is
all that being accepted i mean it's not
like i don't imagine you're suggesting
reversing the sexual revolution
and disappearing the pill and
contraceptives are you
no i'm talking about renorming society
in a more uh reasonable direction
which we do all the time i mean
human beings do learn from mistakes and
one of the
prime examples of this is what's
happened with tobacco smoking
over the last 60 years and i say this
not to knock
smokers um but everybody knows there's
been a sea change
everybody knows that decades of evidence
about the negative effects of this
substance
um made it um easier for people to quit
and made it um more stigmatized than it
had been tobacco use indoors is very
stigmatized at least in the united
states
and all of this was the result of
empirical evidence
eventually filtering down to individual
decisions and that i think
is what needs to happen with the sexual
revolution because
the costs of it are not only you know on
the individual level of romance
and not only in our increasingly
untethered
woke politics but also
the shrinkage of the family and the
fracturing of the family
has raised the cost of the welfare state
across the western world
the state has had to come in and be that
substitute daddy
the state simultaneously bankrolls the
uh broken family um and
and and has to so these are
pretty major consequences that affect
the most advanced economies of the world
in every single country
uh so we're not talking about private
consensual transactions here and that's
what's really
ironic to me in the long run is that
everybody says this is only about
private decisions right
sexual matters are completely off the
table we can't talk about this stuff
it's all private and it's all about
consent
and yet nothing has done as much to
transform our world
as this revolution has socially
politically
uh as and as i mentioned in primal
screams
you know psychologically and otherwise
so it's
something we probably ought to look at
it seems to me
you know and again going back to it
so i i was a teacher for many many years
and the children who struggled the most
at school
whether it was academically whether it
was with the discipline whether it was
the structure
were always children who came from
broken homes who didn't have a father
around
but it was always a great debut you can
never say it because then you're
demonizing single mothers and you're
punching down on single mothers
etc etc and one of the things i found
really powerful about
your book is is the way that you
approach this issue
in particular the long-term implications
for children not having a man around the
house would you be able to explain that
a little bit more mary
this is the best known fact in sociology
and it has been
for decades it's just that nobody wants
to
emphasize it for obvious reasons not
having a biological father in the house
raises risks to children
period it raises risks of physical and
sexual abuse by mom's boyfriends
and it also seems to
make it harder for male children to
become
men that is functioning reasonable
men again for obvious reasons so
in primal screams as you know i'm trying
to do something new with this debate
because it is so
ossified um it's not really even a
debate this stuff is so taboo
and that's why i get into the research
on animals especially
mammals because i think that gives us a
safer way of talking about some of these
things
during the past couple of decades
scientists have
learned a lot that they did not expect
about animal behavior
number one animals are intensely
familial the myth of the lone wolf which
i open
the book with is just that it's a myth
wolves don't run around alone
wolves run around in packs we would call
nuclear families actually typically mom
dad
pups and it's not only wolves
look at just about any mammal um and you
find the same pattern
so this is important because first of
all
it goes to show that at least in nature
as far as nature is concerned
animals aren't a bunch of atomized
beings who are out there
you know finding their glitter families
and their substitute families no animals
exist and flourish
in a biologically related family
the other thing is social learning this
is terribly important
i think scientists now know that animals
learn by watching other animals
in particular they learn by watching
their
mothers and their siblings and their
fathers
why does this matter well i give the
example of the
the cat that can go up a tree but can't
get down the tree which is something
scientists have studied
because some cats can get out of trees
and some cats can't
the working theory is that the cats that
know how to climb down out of the trees
are those
who learned by watching their siblings
or their mothers or their fathers
and cats who can't get out of trees
didn't learn that because they were
isolated from their families typically
house cats
so that's really interesting does it
apply to us i think it very much applies
to us
consider the family is smaller
fathers are absent many people
don't have siblings or a sibling of the
same sex or a sibling of the opposite
sex
or cousins of the opposite sex or
cousins of the same sex
what i'm saying is for all that we think
we're so sophisticated
and advanced we actually have shrunk the
number of people
we can learn from effectively and
i think again we're seeing this on a on
a social
scale people often remark
say about transgenderism uh
homosexuality that it seems
these things seem to have exploded in
recent times and that it's not just that
these things have been destigmatized
it's also that they're growing in real
numbers
my response to that is we have taken
out of our lives i mean inadvertently
but really
uh the kinds of ways in which people
used to learn about the opposite sex
from a young age
for example how could there not be
confusion
given what we've done to ourselves given
all
of those acts of subtraction from our
lives
so the idea that people are now
struggling extra hard to find their
identities
is not an idea that comes as a surprise
if you read what happens with animals
when animals are separated from their
families and communities
and the dysfunctional behavior they
exhibit
when they are living in that unnatural
way
hey francis do you like to keep your
online activity
private yes um i mean sure think about
everything you've ever browsed
searched for watched or tweeted now
imagine all of that data is being
crawled through collected and aggregated
by third parties
into a permanent public record
you are trigonometry is now going to be
a solo project
there are hundreds of data brokers out
there whose sole business is to buy and
sell your data
that's why i use expressvpn with
expressvpn my connection gets
routed through an encrypted server and
my ip address is masked my career is
over
enough about the good news every time i
turn expressvpn on i'm given a random ip
address
shared by other expressvpn customers
that makes it more difficult for third
parties
to identify me or harvest my data i'm
finished i'm absolutely
done and the best part is how easy it is
to use
no matter what device you're on phone
laptop or smart tv
all you have to do is tap one button to
get protected
come on francis you can do the last bit
come on let's do this
uh if you don't want to end up like me
go to expressvpn.com
trigger and get three extra months for
free
that's expressvpn.com
slash trigger go to exp r
e s s v p n dot com
slash trigger to learn more
so we can see this very clearly if we're
talking about other species
but we're not very good at seeing it in
ourselves and that's why
i emphasize that research in primal
screams because i hope
it gives us an end run around this
static discussion about
fatherlessness and etc that so many
people find hard to engage in
why do they find it so hard to engage in
because you know
you talk about uh having other people
in your family to teach you stuff that
certainly resonates with my experience
you know
i learned more about being a man from my
grandfather than i did from my father i
would say
uh and me yes from you yeah i yeah i
learned a lot
um anyway uh so i i totally get that
and it's not a political statement to me
to say that
children need parents and they need
grandparents and they need family
members to be around
and you learn different things from
different people and you know
grandparents are important not only
because they're just another person but
they're from a different generation
they've had their children maybe the
aspirations for their children have
relaxed a little bit now they can just
be
playful with the grandchildren like all
of that is important
and none of that seems in any way
controversial to me and i'm a sort of
like
non-religious uh you know sort of
liberal guy living in a big city
in western in western europe why can't
we
why why you say that we can't talk about
this for obvious reasons why
has the debate become as ossified as you
say
well sometimes i think it's because
we are in the position of
say white people in the american south
pre-civil war that is to say
everybody is affected by this
institution of slavery
in that time or i nowadays i would say
everybody's affected by the sexual
revolution
everybody's implicated um and people
know
that there's something wrong on the
other hand they don't want to go around
hurting everybody's feelings and that's
what this reluctance is about it's about
not wanting to hurt
as you said francis the single mom right
single moms are doing heroic stuff
they're doing the work of two
people so nobody wants to hurt their
feelings but at some point
someone has to ask what the cumulative
effect of this
is on kids so
in the united states for example i've
just read the umpteenth story about the
fentanyl
explosion and before that there was of
course the heroin explosion and before
that the opioid explosion
simultaneously psychiatric diagnosis of
depression and anxiety have been rising
i've been chronicling this for 20 years
this was happening long before
covid the picture i'm painting here is
one of
widespread pretty serious psychological
dissolution
and i don't think that's a picture that
professionals would
quibble over because they know that it's
true
again we have to push through some of
that resistance
in the interests of the people who are
most affected by this
which i think amounts to younger people
when we saw those protesters in the
streets
you know wrecking things and um
being supremely emotional
um i was seeing something on their faces
which was real
misery and real suffering i think
conservatives
and i include myself in this make a
mistake
when we dismiss these bizarre actings
out as snowflake-ism or something that
is the product of an overly privileged
childhood
that's not what i see in this i see real
suffering
and the problem is they've come up with
the wrong
names for this thing the problem out
there
is not some abstraction like
heteronormativity
right i think that's right anyway um the
problem is not
uh feminism
even the problem is much more primal
than that
it's that a lot of people are
psychologically
um unhinged by the fact that they have
not been able to
attach to family community
i would argue religion is part of that
although i agree that
um there are substitute forms of
what joseph bottom called bastard
christianity is floating around i mean
we see this in climate change we see
this in
other things too um generally the woke
religion
uh so there we have it
and you know it's it's a very very
depressing
but in my opinion accurate analysis of
of what is happening
i guess you know the question that i
really want to ask mary is
how you know how do we roll back from
this now because we've got to this point
it feels to me like a crisis point what
can we actually do as a society to roll
back from it is it you know good
old-fashioned take responsibility and
in in this era that we live in now is
that realistic
it's always realistic i am
hopeful for a couple of reasons one is
that
revivals religious and otherwise
i have a way of you know popping up just
when you least expect to see them
and i agree with you francis that we
have hit
a kind of rock bottom especially with
the
problems among the young and the
suffering among the young
and i think out of that will come
new leaders and new conversations
because human beings are not
meant to live as miserably as many of us
do
so there's that there's always hope
because of that kind of again religious
or other
evangelization i would point out
something
interesting about religion here which is
being in washington dc which is a you
know has a vibrant catholic community
i'm very aware of
sort of what goes on in it most of the
young people
people in their 20s and 30s who are
entering the
catholic church uh are entering it
because
they have been victims of this stuff one
way or another
and they enter the church and embrace
its theology
because they hope to find something more
congruent with the complicated human
beings that they
are you know they're looking for
something that isn't some
two-dimensional
woke religion they're looking for
something um that
corresponds to the depth that they feel
in themselves
so that's kind of interesting in other
words it's not
the old the fuddy-duddies who have been
you know raised
home-schooled etc uh who are becoming
the new backbone of christianity in
america
it's the people who are the walking
wounded and
i think that's going to be an
influential fact for a long time to come
and marry moving on now so towards
because when you were talking in the
book
you addressed the me too movement and
you also discussed pornography
and you were saying that we don't have
good examples of what is a positive
romantic relationship anymore
which in your view is what led us to
this mess where
men and women we we can't seem to get
along anymore
and again i think part of that is
because of the
collapse of fundamental social learning
at one point i sat down and read
hundreds of the metoo
accounts and the thing that was so
striking was this was
this was all roshaman right this was all
the man had one experience of an
encounter the woman had a completely
different experience
and over and over and over nobody seemed
to realize that it's because
men and women are different maybe um
you know just basic stuff like that that
that shouldn't be political and is um
or basic stuff like obviously
pornography
is completely toxic for human
relationships
uh everybody knows that you know an
eleven-year-old who dumps her
boyfriend's
phone knows that what's irritating
is that feminism used to know that and
that here is a place where feminists
once took a strong
stand saying look this is this is bad
for romance this is bad for women this
is bad for men too
and what we have instead now is a
feminism that's
just seems to completely have stockholm
syndrome
about everything and whatever the most
libertarian
guy wants is what feminists today go
along with and
i think that's been a real dissent from
the feminism of yesteryear the feminism
of andrea dworkin which by
the way i don't happen to share but i
can have a lot more respect for
something that at least
stood up to um some obvious
detrimental things in society like
pornography
and and do you think you you've touched
on it several times in different ways
but
i'm kind of hearing out of what you're
saying and please correct me if i'm
not hearing you correctly but the what
what this sexual revolution really did
rather than freeing women
what it really did it freed men and what
men want
isn't necessarily you know biologically
we're programmed to pursue very
different things
if you ask a guy what he'd really want
when it comes to sexual relationships
it'd probably look very different to
what a woman would want and i say this
as someone who's happily monogamous and
married but
i'm not sure that's what i was
biologically programmed to be do you
know what i'm saying
oh i think so i think so um
sure so the sexual revolution
empowered the already powerful that
is the meaning of the metoo movement
um it empowered the already powerful and
it weakened
those who were already in a subordinate
situation
and this is a theme that i come back to
often because i think it matters
as a humanitarian fact the sexual
revolution
falls heaviest on the weakest shoulders
and that
is to say children
adults can engage in all of these
social experiments right and now we have
the idea of chosen families
or glitter families i don't know if
you're familiar with these terms but the
idea is
uh families that you like better than
the ones you were stuck with in the
first place
and that you can have these substitute
families
of those whom you choose
and this is a fashionable thing over
here
um david brooks and others have written
about it favorably
oh what's interesting about that is if
if you ask a six-year-old
what his family is he wouldn't say that
he wants to choose it
he would just want the one that was
handed to him and that's what i mean
you know these are the ways in which um
the way we've come to live make it
harder
for the smallest and weakest who also
can't be expected to understand all of
this
again this is where we're seeing this
increasing immiseration
of the young coming from and it's also
as well i mean
we keep circling around it as well isn't
the fact
you know we're more deeply selfish than
ever before
you know it's about me it's about my my
gratifications
and that has an impact on society even
though we don't like to admit it
so getting back to the differences
between men and women
i had this formulation at one point that
the sexual revolution in men is more
like a slow acting virus that you
don't realize how deadly it can be
until some decades in and
this comes to mind because if we look at
life from the other end of the telescope
from old age we can see how
uh we can see what we've done to
ourselves
so for example in places like japan
where a lot of people
didn't have families didn't stop to have
families uh
and came from small families in the
first place
there is an entire industry surrounding
what are called
lonely deaths i don't know if you're
aware of this but it's because
there's so much solitary living and
people die in
apartments as singletons and
insurance companies have been
transformed to deal with this
and there are companies that go in and
clean out apartments
of people who have no living relatives
etc
that's just to say i'm not bringing that
up to be a debbie downer i'm saying that
when you read a story about how
thousands of people die alone in a place
like japan
every week you can't help but think
this is temporary i mean we're going to
devise
some way around this we're going to
adapt so that there's less of this
in the future and again that's a ground
for hope i would think
we have to be we can't beat ourselves up
um
the way we are living now is really new
compared to everything that came before
us
if you were an illiterate peasant um
in the south of france in the year 1200
you would still be more literate about
family
than a lot of people are today
you would just have those ties they
would be a given they're just an
unbidden thing that you were born into
and you wouldn't question them i mean
it's not until you get to our level of
prosperity
and the innovation of the birth control
pill
that suddenly a lot of people are
questioning this stuff and
uh trying to devise new forms of
connection
this is all very recent so it's no
wonder that it's not well understood and
it's
no wonder that there's such resistance
to talking about it
mary there will be a lot of people
watching this because we have people
from all over the different sides of all
these different conversations watching
the show and if they haven't switched
off yet they're they may be planning to
very shortly so before they do let me
ask you this
i mean people would say i think not
entirely unreasonably that there have
been some great
breakthroughs as a result of the sexual
revolution and
you know they've they have freed women
to to do what they want to do
or at least what they think they want to
do you know there's a
you might have a an argument about that
but surely
you know the traditional maxim of our
time is
you know freedom is great and we've just
we've got more of it isn't that
brilliant
right so that's a very consumerist
attitude and i think we live in a time
when people are rethinking consumerism
at all costs people are rethinking
globalism for example
and this is not to dis freedom as such
but we all know that unlimited
consumerism in
any area is bad for us right
we're moralistic about obesity we're
moralistic about
tobacco smoking um well
why can't we apply the same lens to some
of what's happened
on account of the sexual revolution and
what you might call
you know sexual consumerism uh
consumerism in the sexual marketplace
i think that if anything younger people
who are especially aware of
the need to put limits on some of our
behavior whether it's because of
climate change or for other reasons
those people
of all people would be open to arguments
about
hey maybe we are hurting ourselves by
having unlimited freedom in other areas
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
and mary i'm gonna bring it back to
being depressing again because that is
uh my modus operandi this is his brand
that's my brand that's what i bring to
the party
after i start it's no longer a party and
i'm very proud about it
um but one of the things that you talked
about that i found particularly powerful
is you compared the family to one of the
pillars of our society
and effectively what we're doing
by turning our back on the family is
destabilizing the pillar of our society
well sure um and again this is all
social science that people don't want to
talk about
but uh people kids who have the best
outcomes in school
etc uh the least truancy the least
criminal behavior
are basically coming out of intact homes
and that
holds across the socioeconomic spectrum
again it is hard to talk about this
at a time when so many people don't have
access
to that very model um but
that doesn't make it any less true
um yeah well that's the difficulty and
i'm still you know when i asked you
about
why people don't have this conversation
or scared to
i'm somewhat dissatisfied with with your
answer and it's nothing personal to you
i just
i'm not i just don't understand why
we can't say well if you do this it's
less good than doing something else
without you know still respecting people
because they are in the position that
there are so if you're a single mother
we can say well it's not ideal for your
child but you are doing your best
and we we still respect you for that
it's just maybe
you know you you might be worth you
teaching your child
that actually it would be great for them
to to stay together with their partner
and have children like that like i don't
see how those two things are mutually
exclusive
why is this even a political issue i
just i really don't understand
well we live in a politicized time
that's one reason it's a political issue
but i would like to make it a political
issue in a positive sense
and say maybe we can experiment
politically i'm not a policy wonk but it
does seem to make sense that
there might be policies that would make
it easier for parents to stay together
that would make it easier for parents to
have another child
um there could be tax breaks that way
there could be
um certain
things about family formation that you
could tether to forgiving student loans
i mean there's a lot of room for
creativity in this
and i think that it that seeing
the government do some of that um
might help us down the road might make
it easier to
start and keep a family in the first
place so we should look at that
i i agree i think it is something that
we need to look at when are you
proposing me
my oh we're skipping over that one yeah
we're skipping over that there we go
um i guess what i'm worried about mary
is that i i think as a society
i think we're so wrapped up in
consumerism
i think we're so wrapped up in the
glorification of the self
i'm tied up with identity politics
that the idea of you know
putting others needs first before your
own
i think is seen as a bit old hat and
old-fashioned is it not
well it is but that doesn't make it any
less heroic
i mean there are things about people
that don't change
if we look at the uh
the serious concern over climate change
for example
and the way in which people make
sacrifices
on in the name of that right um
turning off their air conditioning uh
not going on airplanes
etc in extreme cases there are people
who argue
one shouldn't even have children because
of climate change
but what that example goes to show is
that we have a sacrificial side to
ourselves
and it's just been displaced onto these
more
abstract ventures um
[Music]
it's not impossible to think that we can
turn that back to its natural position
which is
sacrificing in marriage sacrificing uh
by having family etc
we should make it cool to post pictures
of of yourself being married on
instagram i think that that's
that's that's the way you solve it uh
well it's interesting because you know
francis obviously brings in the voice of
pessimism but i get the sense from you
that you are
uh well the way i would interpret it is
you think things have got so bad that we
can only
go up from here yeah there was a novel
in the 70s
with that very title been down so long
it looks like up to me
i don't know whether you've heard of it
but that's uh yeah
that's the idea i mean the bottom line
is that
we are living in ways unnatural to the
kind of creatures that we are
we need to recognize that just as we can
recognize
in other creatures in fellow creatures
when they are living in ways out of
keeping with their natures
that's what i'm trying to do in my work
is shine a light
on that uh
i'm a conservative precisely because
i don't think we've been very good at
coming up with
new answers to ancient questions like
who am i
my hope is that we can also dig into the
past and recover some of that wisdom
and bring it to bear on these very new
problems that we have like
psychiatric dissolution among the young
and and you talk about
you know ancient you know ancient
questions
isn't the problem as well for men is
they're not it's not that they're
obsolete
it's just that their their position in
society
isn't as clear-cut as it used to be and
as a result has not that has that
not created a kind of crisis within men
as well
yes very much so i think
and deriding the masculine
principle as happens in everyday
discourse
in all of the mainstream media is not
going to
help that again if you think of the
plight of a
young boy growing up today about half of
them
in the united states are being raised in
families without the father present
typically after some cataclysmic
happening like divorce
meaning that the message a lot of them
are getting are men
are bad right um and
that can't help but confuse a boy and
and be a toxic factor in his life
so if we can't have real fathers we can
have
substitute fathers i wouldn't be
surprised to see
religion re-emerging in a surprising way
in this kind of wreckage now as far as
the catholic church the catholic church
has
like impressive history of own goals
put very mildly there very well
but uh you know
it offers at its best
a paternal principle that
people can understand and it offers for
example the figure of saint joseph as a
substitute father
so there's still a language there that
broken people of our time
can work with and i wouldn't be
surprised to see
again unexpected but real religious
revival coming out of this
because that's at least more tangible
that gives you more to hold on to
than a glitter family or a chosen
family or in the long run identity
politics
and do you think that that would be a
force for good
this reinvention you know and you know
the reawakening of
religion i think
anything that gives atomized purposeless
people
a source of positive meaning
is good right now we need that we could
use a lot more of that
you know it's interesting when
i talk about how this the identity
politics are related to the sexual
revolution
there is a particular document that i
would like to point to here which is
the first document in which the phrase
identity politics was used
it was done in 1977 by a group of
radical african-american feminists
it's called the kambahi river collective
and
in this statement uh which is a very sad
statement
these women say we are giving up on the
people around us
especially the men around us we don't
think they have our backs
we don't think we can work with them
anymore we can only work with people
exactly like we are
that's the founding statement of
identity politics it appears in 1977
just as the sexual revolution is taking
hold
and i think it's it's incredibly uh
evocative because it shows that identity
politics
is born not out of liberation
but out of desperation to find
people and create a community in a world
where communities were already weakening
so that is something that we should all
think about when we think about identity
politics think about
that document and think of it as a
statement of resignation
a statement about giving up on most of
the rest of the human race
that's where identity politics is coming
from
our former prime minister margaret
thatcher said there's no such thing as
society there's only men women children
and families
and it goes back to what you're saying
which is you know without families we
we don't have a functioning society
pretty much that and we're finding it
out
the empirical evidence is all around us
uh we just need to acknowledge it
and move on somehow whether it's through
politics or
through personal behavior uh mary
it's been great talking to you it's a
perspective that we've done often here
uh certainly in the mainstream which is
why we we wanted to speak with you about
it
uh thank you for talking to us and as we
as you know we have one more question
for you
which is of course what is the one thing
that we're still not talking about as a
society that we really should be
well so since i'm talking to a couple of
agnostics
or atheists um agnostics don't lump us
in
with the with the hardcore okay
uh i would like to put one thought out
there
uh at a time when organized religion is
seems to be in free fall which is that
really our theotropic nature
as human beings is inerraticable if we
don't have organized religion we will
make up
other religions and i really believe
that out of the sexual revolution has
been created a substitute religion
that has its own uh secular saints like
margaret sanger
and alfred kinsey and margaret mead
uh it has its own uh rituals
and it is reminiscent of christianity in
in many
ways which is to say when people think
that religion is something
we've put behind us because we're
somehow smarter and better than
anyone who came before us i would like
people to stop and reflect
on the religiosity of our time the
secular religiosity of our time
well listen we mentioned that we're
non-believers but
that is an issue we've been thinking
quite a lot about in recent years
uh because it's becoming unavoidable and
inescapable and certainly
the fact that people seem to be waking
up to a different religion now
uh you know it's everywhere and the
similarities are so
blindingly obvious that even people like
us who i think otherwise would quite
like to pretend that it's not there
are starting to go yeah i think
there might be something to this uh so
yeah
it's a good point and well made uh mary
thank you so much for
coming on the show uh the book is called
primal screams how the sexual revolution
created identity politics
thoroughly recommend for people to get
that is anywhere else you'd like people
to go and find you online
i have a website maryeberstat.com where
they can read about uh whatever
i've been spouting off about lately and
the books and etc
and thank you constantine and francis
well thank you very much mary you've
indeed been an
absolutely wonderful guest go make sure
to go and check out mary
online if you uh have enjoyed this
episode
or they come out on wednesdays and
sundays and we also
come out on wednesdays and sundays even
if you haven't enjoyed yeah absolutely
yeah
works both ways yeah and we have
trigonometry raw which comes out on
tuesday thursday
friday and saturday and they always go
out 7pm uk time
take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below